Okay.
So Sarah Huckabee Sanders is leaving the Trump
administration as press secretary.
And we talked late last year about reports
that she was going to be, uh, leaving her
position as a completely dishonest and disgusting
press secretary at the end of 2018 that didn't
happen.
It took a little longer, but she is leaving
at the end of this month and she is going
to be leaving the White House and the Trump
administration, uh, in a state of total, um,
uh, uh, dishonesty and embarrassment for the
relationship that the Trump administration
has had to the press corps.
Remember that she has not actually done a
press briefing for just under a hundred days.
I don't remember the exact number, but it's
the first half of I think march that she did
her last press briefing.
So in a sense it's a perfect time to leave
because she's basically been missing as press
secretary for a long time.
This announced of course, uh, by presidential
tweet, Donald Trump putting the most positive
possible spin on it, saying quote, after three
and a half years, our wonderful Sarah Huckabee
Sanders will be leaving the White House at
the end of the month and going home to the
great state of Arkansas.
She is a very special person with extraordinary
talents who has done an incredible job.
I hope she decides to run for governor of
Arkansas.
She would be fantastic.
Sarah.
Thank you for a job well done.
I actually can't think of any extraordinary
talent that Sarah Huckabee Sanders possesses
other than the ability, and I guess it is
a sort of talent.
Most people would, would cringe at doing it.
She does have the extraordinary talent of
being able to tell absolutely disgusting,
provable lies with no visible shame or embarrassment
on her facial expression and in the context
of the Trump administration and defending
what she's had to defend for these three and
a half years.
I guess that does take something akin to talent
or skill.
And again, on the merits.
Hilariously, it barely matters that she's
leaving because as far as the press briefings
are concerned, there hasn't been one in nearly
100 days.
And it's really, really important that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders actions and her role in the
propaganda machine of the Trump administration
not be sanitized.
In retrospect, I've, we've talked about how
we've got to be careful when we talk about
ways in which George W. Bush was not as bad
as Donald Trump in terms of his diplomatic
skills, relationships to allies, whatever.
We don't want to be incorrectly looking back
at Bush with rose colored glasses because
he was a horrible war, more monger who, uh,
supervised absolutely terrible economic circumstances
and bone headed military decision after military
decision.
But in some ways he wasn't as bad as Trump
in the same way.
You know, Sean Spicer was terrible, truly,
but Sarah Huckabee Sanders was much worse
and we can't allow her image to be retroactively
or retrospectively rather sanitized.
She concocted not just political lies, but
just straight up obvious lies.
Like when she said that when Donald Trump
fired James Comey in May of 2017 that a bunch
of people from the FBI had reached out to
her and said they like the the, the president
fired James Comey.
That was a complete and total lie.
She admitted that that was a complete and
total lie under oath when she was interviewed
by Robert Mueller's investigation.
So this is concocting a false story, whole
cloth, not a slip of the tongue as she called
it.
And I could sit here and just list a bunch
of these demonstrably false lies that she's
concocted.
Many of you already know them.
The point is she needs to be remembered for
shameless line.
And Paul Waldman wrote in The Washington Post
over the weekend about this and he said, quote,
in a more just world, Sanders would be shamed
and shunned forever.
She wouldn't be able to get job.
Her neighbors would avoid her.
She would be regarded with the universal contempts.
She has so richly earned.
It's not the world we live in.
She'll be welcomed back in Arkansas or some
kind of hero.
She will be a top prospect for all sorts of
big companies with nice salaries and Trump,
actually, I don't know if he's joking by saying
she could be governor of Arkansas.
She probably will have a good shot at being
the governor of Arkansas at some point in
time.
Her track record of lies and deception have
almost qualified her for future riches and
prominent prestigious positions.
And that's a bigger problem than her.
That's a bigger problem than Trump.
It's a far bigger problem.
But when we talk about a degenerate sycophant
uh, we're really talking about someone exactly
like Sarah Huckabee Sanders.
That's who comes to mind to me.
Let me know what you think about her departure
and the timing of it.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show.
It is
a very,
very good shows you that